Chip Huyen:
Hello, everyone.
Hey there.
So, I am Chip.
Thank you so much for
coming to my talk.
My career has been mostly
with building AI systems,
trying to make AI useful
in the real world.
So, I started with NVIDIA; and
then I worked on Snorkel AI,
which is a data company.
And then, I started another
AI infrastructure startup,
which I sold.
And since then, I'm doing a new
company, which is in robotics.
Anyone here is into robotics?
One person.
So, yeah. So this is a bunch
of robots that I work with.
Like this one, I'm trying to fit
the ring on the robot hands,
which is weird because they
don't quite have the same width
as human fingers.
But, yeah.
So, today the talk is about
software defensibility,
because that's the type
questions that have been trying
to think about in
the last few years,
because there are two
things that I thought
of myself as being good at.
One is writing, and
the other is coding.
And I think those are
the top two things
that AI could easily
automate nowadays.
So, it makes me feel like, okay.
So, what should I do that
I can reasonably defend
in the age of AI?
So, how many people
here consider yourself
a software engineer?
Whoa. A lot of you.
How many of you are worried
about AI automating your job?
One person.
Okay. Few more people.
I think this is the kind of
thing you don't say out loud.
It's like, yes.
Keep it a secret.
Okay. So, one thing I keep
hearing people telling me is
that the cost of building
software is approaching zero.
So, I keep hearing
people saying, okay.
It's extremely cheap right
now to generate code, right?
You can just get AI and it can
write you an app, a feature,
build a website extremely fast.
So, I keep hearing companies
who, in the past,
maybe they could only
create maybe like 10,
20 variations for A/B testing.
Now they could generate like
1.000 variations
for A/B testing,
because it costs
extremely cheap.
So, it made me
think about, okay.
If the cost of building
software is approaching zero,
does that mean that the value
of building software is also
approaching zero, right?
If the cost is zero,
then the value is zero.
So, it makes me
think about, so it's
like, it made me realize,
it's like, okay.
What should it be
building, right?
What is the point of
building anything nowadays
if there's no value
associated with it?
So, a few months ago I had
launched a side project.
It's a weekend project.
I like it.
It's fun. It got some traction,
300,000 views within a weekend.
And then, within a day, somebody
emailed me saying that,
"I love what you did."
So, I asked Claude Code
to do exactly that;
and here's the link
to the website,
exactly what you just built.
So, I felt very
ambivalent about it, right.
I was like, on the one
hand, I'm flattered.
Thank you.
But, on the other hand,
what the heck, man?
It's just here's your token,
and I copy and paste it.
So, it makes me realize,
it's like any software
that exists today can easily
be replicated, right?
If you can ask AI to Airtable,
it can build it.
If you ask it to do Asana,
And I see there's a
lot of this coming.
I'm actually building
this side project.
It's called kill, kill by
gpt.com where we can vote
on which product is going
to be killed by AI first.
I'm launching it next
week, hopefully.
And you guys can use Claude
Code to replicate it.
But, yeah.
So, I'm just curious.
Yeah. So, it made me feel
like more excitement,
because now I can build
anything that I want.
But, at the same time, anyone
can build anything that I want.
And, of course, not everything
is the same, right?
People talking about, okay.
Not everything can
be easily buildable,
because you cannot just build
Google in a weekend, right?
But, at the same
time, I see that --
are you familiar with
METR, like M-E-T-R?
So, they just study the
progress of AI automations.
And they do a benchmark.
Okay. Let's take on the tasks
that usually take,
let's say, an hour.
How often that AI can reliably
complete the task, right?
So, it benchmarks on the length
of tasks that AI can complete
about 50 percent of the time.
And you can see this.
Okay. In the beginning
it starts very little,
like a few seconds of the task.
But now we can reliably complete
tasks that take like 16 hours.
So, it's a very long horizon,
extremely complicated task,
right, because I feel like,
for a lot of engineers,
I don't think people can
just sit down for 16 hours
and code something
extremely complex.
So, yeah. So, things have
been getting very complex,
so maybe AI cannot build Google
nowadays, given the trajectory.
So, this is log
scale, by the way.
But if you do linear
scale, it will look
like very much like
an exponential.
So, things like AI can, at
some point, get there.
So, I think it's like the
"Ghibli moment of software."
So, did anyone use OpenAI
to generate Ghibli picture
style of yourself?
So, in the past, I feel
like there's a trend
of everyone using
image generation
to generate a style Ghibli,
and then I was thinking
that there's no way
Ghibli agrees with this.
There's no way.
But, also, as a point, we think
of like a style is
something like,
if you can describe a
style, it's a shorthand
for the AI to know what to do.
And the artists were
very upset, right,
because they spent the whole
career developing the style,
and we could just do it.
And I think it's
similar with software.
Anything that exists, just
make it easier for people
to shorthand and
build it, right.
Maybe if they want to
do something like Asana.
It'd take me a lot
harder to describe.
Okay. Here's the specs.
Here's the functionality.
Here's the workflow.
But, if it already exists, I can
say, okay, let's just do it.
You know what it is, right?
So, by the act of you
putting out the software,
you make it easier
for the competitor
to do exactly what he wants.
So, the question with AI is
no longer how to build.
Now, if you know what you
want to do, it's very easy.
The question is, is like
what you build; and then,
once you build it,
how do you defend it?
So, I'm curious.
What do you think would be
the moat for your product?
Anyone here is doing a startup?
A few more.
So, I'm curious what do you
think would be the moat
for your software startup?
Huh?
Proprietary data.
So, who here
thinks of data as a moat?
A few people.
So, you think that, if you have
a lot of proprietary data,
competitors cannot
compete with you.
Okay. What else?
What else would you consider
like a moat for a company?
Huh? Trust, like branding.
Trust, branding.
It's another very
interesting question.
Who else? What else?
Customer service.
The human layer.
So, when you say
customer service,
it's like AI agent
as customer service?
I see. Interesting.
I feel like more and more I
veer toward just not going
through human service.
I feel like they can
get away with it.
I would probably like to
try something automated.
But it's interesting.
So, the question of
trust, I think it's
like people have realized,
it's like, trust is not
sufficient because, in the past,
people were a lot more
loyal to your product.
But with AI, because the steps
change, the improvement is
so significant, so you can
see people switch models very
quickly, right?
When ChatGPT first came out,
everyone thought, okay.
There's no way something can
compete with ChatGPT, right?
And then Saturday, right,
Claude Anthropic came
out and said, okay,
now I can do it.
And then DeepSeek came
out, and everyone,
a lot would jump to it.
Then DeepSeek turned out
to not work quite well;
will jump to Qwen.
So, I think a lot of the
product we have seen
that customer loyalty is hard
to compete with improvement,
like product improvement.
But I think I definitely
agree with you,
just like, building trust is
never going to be a pain.
On the question of data,
so data, I used to think
that like, proprietary
data is the most, right,
because you have a lot of data,
then we're going to
compete with you.
But then I realized,
given how many companies,
how much money companies are
spending on acquiring data,
then data is no longer a moat.
Money is a moat, right?
If you have money,
you can just buy it.
Have you seen a lot
of AI frontier labs buying
companies just to get the data?
Have you seen that?
So, if you see, look at
the frontier labs or a list
of their acquiring companies,
some of them acquire companies,
like two or three companies
a week, because the reason is
that, acquire companies so
that they can get data
from that company.
So, maybe the competitors
do not have the data,
but maybe a frontier lab can
acquire the competitors' data
and then build something
that works quite well
for the use case.
And it's quite
interesting because,
given how fast people were able
to build a model, a new launch,
a new model, to compete
with existing models.
It turns out that acquiring data
is not the hard part anymore.
And, if it has anything,
it's more like a commodity.
So, let's say that you
have a QuickBooks, right?
And you say, QuickBooks will
never sell data to OpenAI.
But OpenAI can just go
to my scale AI search,
Micron, and say, Okay.
Now, create a software that
looks exactly like QuickBooks.
Hire like 10,000 accountants
that do all the
workflow you need
as if you were using
QuickBooks, and then use
that data to train the model.
So, people can do
that pretty quickly,
and that's why the oldest data
labeling companies have revenues
of like a billion dollars
because they create a lot
of data extremely,
extremely fast.
Another thing people told me
about is distributions, right,
especially for enterprise.
Let's say they have spent
like months and months trying
to get the software
into the customers.
And they work with, I don't
know, Oracle and like stuff;
I know it's very much
embedded into the ecosystem.
It shouldn't be really hard for
people to move away from it.
I think it's, like, just still
a lot of validity in it
but also want to
ask about, okay.
How about for consumer
products, right?
And some things that, like, do
not require heavy integrations.
And a lot was like, oh, I
really do not know, right,
because the consumer product,
like this and that, is,
like, a pretty much easy
issue to replicate.
And also having a distribution
as a moat also makes
a few a bit uneasy,
because the entire
moat strategy depends
on people's annoyance, right?
Something that makes it
extremely hard to use,
so that people cannot
get off your platform.
And also another interesting
model is that I have a friend
who used to be a partner with
a very big firm, like PV firm.
And he also tried to sell to a
lot of manufacturers, right.
And if you go through
compare old school project,
old school approach,
you have to go reach
out to all these
manufacturers, and,
okay, try to sell to them.
And what he did was that, okay.
He just bought a software
company that already has
like 10,000 factories
as a customer.
It was like, okay.
These software companies,
they're not AI companies,
it's actually a lot cheaper.
If you have AI money, you can
go and buy these companies;
and that's why you can
own the distributions.
So, distribution, in a way, can
be acquired with more money.
Another I thought
about is expertise.
So, people were like, okay.
But I know the domain
the best, right?
I have years and years of
iterations and make it the best.
But expertise is interesting
because expertise,
for it to be useful, you have
to encode it somewhere, right?
You don't want to
be a service model
when you can just use exchange
service for hourly money, right,
talk to people or not.
So, you want to
just scale it, so
that means that you encode that.
And now, expertise
becomes software.
And all the workflows, if you
spend years and years designing,
can be just copied; and people
can just use that as a workflow.
So, I think exactly one thing
that I realized is just
like, what part is momentum, so
the only way to spend ahead
of customers, like
your competitors,
is just to move
faster than them.
And I think it makes a lot of
pressure for a lot of companies,
because now, you want
to build product.
You're committed to a
never-ending treadmill
of just doing faster and
faster than the competitors,
which is for a lot of
people it's great.
People love it.
But it just creates a lot of
pressure on the part of how
to stay with the competitors.
How do you feel so far?
Is this too bleak?
So, here's a question
of what to build.
I think it's a lot of form.
I do think it's like a
lot of value in building,
because building, one thing is,
I do spend a lot of time.
Right now, I have both Claude
Code and Codex running,
because I feel like it's
just like building.
And building things, I feel
like it makes me a better
problem solver, right?
It's because, when
you're building,
you don't build products that
exist in a vacuum, right?
You build something to address
some annoyances that you have.
So, building just, like, helps
me understand
the problems I want
to solve more and have
the experience of, okay.
Here's a problem; here's a
solution I think would work.
Let's build it and launch it.
And I put it in front of users,
and I see what
they say about it.
But, if you want to build it
as a company, as a startup,
then you need to think
about not just like today,
but how it's going to work two
years from now on because,
under the case, I actually
invested in this company.
And they did great for
the first three years.
My first three years,
I grew from my zero ARRs
and a 10 million ARR.
And now they just
don't know, okay.
Now we have 10 million ARR,
but then they cannot
get to 100 million ARR.
And in a lot of VC world,
it's got stuck, right?
You're not going to be
big enough to go IPO.
But then, what do you do next?
So, yeah. So, anyway,
it's very easy to keep
on building, CLE momentum.
And then don't know, if
you don't have a strategy
of going big, it's
hard to raise money.
So, one thing is, I do
have this belief that,
no matter how good AI is, there
will always be
problems to solve,
because I think it's like,
no matter how good AI is,
I would never stop being angry
at people on the internet.
And I would never
stop being angry
at like, united customer
service, right?
There's a lot of
problems that it's just
like, AI will not solve.
And I do think it's like,
as AI becomes better,
it expands the
surface areas, right.
As AI allow us to build more
use cases, as I expand,
it might not be the same
problems that we had before;
but I introduce new problems.
And I want to cover a few
categories of problems,
of things that have
emerged with AI.
So, before I go into that,
I think a major problem
is a long-tail problem.
It's a long-tail distribution.
So, there are problems
everyone faces, right?
Everyone wants to
write better emails.
A lot of people want
to write better code.
A lot of people want to help
with small little
things like, okay.
Fix my essay.
Do my homework.
So, they're like a category
of very, very big problems
that I do believe that a lot
of AI frontier labs will try
to get the models to
do well on, right.
Now, let's look at them.
Okay. Here are the problems
that face maybe 99 percent
as a population, versus the
problems that face maybe,
like, 1 percent of
the population.
Then AI frontier lab will
probably focus on the ones
of like 99 percent
a population has.
So, that's one reason why a lot
of this AI lab still focuses
on a few standard use cases,
and a lot of them still
focus on English.
For many, many languages,
for example, Arabic,
AI actually doesn't
quite work well.
Doesn't work quite well.
So, I have a friend
who is Iranian.
And she told me this.
She's a professor at CMU, so
she does a lot of work with AI.
And she tells a story,
because she speaks Farsi,
is that the language,
Farsi, right?
Sorry. I feel very
stupid right now.
Yeah, Farsi.
And she has an issue of
her friends would ask her
to explain a sentence,
like an idiom in Farsi.
And she explains a sentence
that, oh, that means like that.
And that friend was like, No.
You're lying, because apparently
ChatGPT gives a different answer
to that different answer.
And so, friends somehow
trust ChatGPT more.
Even my friend's like, "No, no.
I am correct."
But just because ChatGPT doesn't
do very well in Farsi language.
So, yeah. So they
work with some,
a lot of the voice chatbot.
And another problem with voice
chatbot is that you have
to respond very fast, right.
Like a human, human to human
interactions, so latency is
like you want it to be under
like 800 milliseconds for it
to be like good, reasonable,
natural conversations.
But, for voice chatbot, it has
to go through three steps.
So, first step it should
be able to translate
from audio into text, right?
And then, you send the text to
an LM to get back to response.
And then you send the response
to what I call text-to-speech
to synthesize the voice
to send it back to users.
So, a challenge we have was that
this voice chat work really well
for English, because the speed
of synthesizing English
is pretty fast.
But, for Arabic or
Russian, it's extremely slow.
So, it's like it's really,
really hard to create
natural voice chatbots
for different languages.
So, yeah. So I think I see for
a lot of long-tail problems,
I do see the AI labs
as not quite doing it.
And it doesn't mean that
they're not doing it
like two years from now on.
But I can see that, if you
can pick a problem, that is,
I think of them as big enough to
be profitable but not big enough
that AI frontier
labs wouldn't want
to take the launch,
that kind of thing.
Okay. So, here's some
of the long-tail problems
I could find, I thought
was interesting.
One is human preferences.
Are you here familiar with RLHF?
Have you heard of the term
reinforcement learning
by human preference?
You heard of the term.
So, yeah. So, in the early days
of LM, in the early day of GPT-4
and as early day of these
models, RLHF is one of the most,
I think, most popular terms
that people want to understand.
So, the way the model trained,
they trained the model is
that they want the AI to
go to generate responses
that humans prefer, right?
So, it wouldn't give a prompt,
and it gave two
responses side by side.
And then the human would pick.
Okay; this is the one
that I like more.
And then you would use
that to train the model,
to nudge it toward sharing
more better responses.
So, a challenge with that
is that it's trying
to encode human preference into
one equation, so it assumes
that there's some like
universal preference, right,
like everyone somehow
prefers the same thing.
So, when I was going through the
Anthropic RLHF datasets they
made online, I realized a lot
of what people consider the
winning responses, actually I do
not prefer the winning response.
I actually prefer the
losing responses,
just like somehow the note
is like, smart is not better.
So, human preferences
are extremely hard,
and it requires you
understand users very well.
So, going back to the
voice chatbot, right,
so humans actually have a very
different preference of how fast
the other person responds.
So, I'm from Vietnam.
So, in Vietnam, people actually
prefer the other person
to give them time
before a response.
So, I have a niece
who is 10 years old,
and I have my godmother, who's
a 70 year-old American woman.
So, I tried to put
them on a call,
and it was the worst experience.
So, the thing, so
when my godmother,
she tried to be friendly, right.
So, when my niece
took time to respond,
my godmother was like, okay.
She is shy.
She doesn't know how to talk,
and she didn't want
the awkward silence.
So, she kept, if my niece
wait a little bit long
and didn't say anything,
my godmother kept
on asking questions, right?
And then, after that, my niece
told me, it's like, wow.
She didn't give me any
time to respond at all.
So, it turns out,
there's actually
a well-known study about it.
It's about, in the West,
people actually prefer
conversation respond rates to be
very fast, maybe
18 milliseconds.
If you finish talking, you
expect me to respond very,
very fast, whereas in some
cultures, like Vietnam,
after you finish talking,
you give the person maybe
like 200 milliseconds so that
the other person can make sure
the other person has finished
and formulates a response.
So, all of these
nuances you need to go
to understand the customers
to build a product
that works quite well.
So, I guess part of the
expertise as part of the moat,
it's more like user
understanding, understanding
who you're building for.
Another thing is, like, the
human-AI interactions.
And, since we're at Microsoft
Build, I want to talk
about a lot of you are,
like, software engineers.
How many of you are using AI
to write code right now?
Almost all of you.
Yeah. How many of you are
using it via the Terminal?
Some of you.
Right. How many of
you use it via ID?
How many use both?
Okay. Well, most of
you use both.
So, when I was looking,
it's like Terminal is a
very interesting product.
So, Terminal, I think of it
as a more legacy product.
Do you think that Terminal is
easy to use or hard to use?
Who thinks terminals
are easy to use?
One person, right.
Few people.
So, Terminal, when I started
using Terminal for writing code,
it got pretty annoying, right?
It's very hard to move
the cursor around.
You kind of just throw
an image in there.
If you see a user-built
website, it's like, okay.
This is, like, a
horrible interface.
I want AI to see that
this is terrible,
but I cannot easily
drop an image in there.
And it's made me think, why
are terminals so hard to use?
And it made me think of, okay.
Terminals are actually
very powerful.
Terminals are like a control
plane for the computer, right?
It's very easy to do
stupid things there.
You can remove RF.
They can remove the
whole operating system,
and you could be,
like, in trouble.
So, terminals, in a way, was
designed to be hard-to-use
on purpose, so that people
who don't know what they are
doing don't do something stupid
by accident, right.
So, IDE, on the other hand,
just makes it
a lot easier to use.
But then I thought about it.
It's like, there's not really
a reason why they need to be
in a separate product, right?
One of them is, like, ease of
use, and the other makes it,
like, harder to control.
So, I think, what if we have
something just like as a hybrid.
And I think it's like a lot
of those Codex desktops,
or like Claude Code desktop,
or like a different desktop,
design should be a
mixture of it, right.
It has an ease of
use of like IDE,
but then you also allow each
access of file systems,
the ways that a terminal can,
so that it may give you
that more power.
And another thing is about it,
people have quickly realized
that which was so good we
quickly realize this is like,
have you ever walked around
with your computer open
because of Claude Code or Codex
is running on the computer?
Yeah. I think I walk
around the airport.
And, when I see somebody
walking around open, okay;
that person has
something running.
So, there's no reason why
you need to do that, right,
because I even think about
all the work is being done
on the cloud.
There's no reason why you need
to keep the computer
open to run it.
But, then, so there's a lot of
tools to make it easy for you
to access, to make your things
run without the computer.
So, somebody likes to
open Claude early in the day.
A lot of people bought the
MacBook Mini, so the idea is
that you have a server
that hosts your agent
so that you can just leave
it running all the time;
so you don't need
to use the computer.
But after that it creates a
whole challenge of like, okay.
You need to create a sandbox.
You need to copy to
recreate the environment.
So, now it has to be on the
cloud so you can access
from a different device,
and there are some people
who create mobile apps so you
can control the Claude Code
or Codex from the mobile phone.
Actually, one of my
fun projects was
like, I can actually
control my Claude Code
from my Telegram bot.
So, it could send me messages.
Okay. Now it's done;
they ask me yes,
no questions, they can, okay.
Do it. Do it.
So, I think all of that
human-AI interaction is
quite interesting.
Another challenge, another
example with GitHub,
so, I imagine a lot of
you probably use GitHub
for code review,
collaborations, right?
And one thing I noticed
with code review is
that people don't review
code the old way anymore.
So, I worked with a
team recently,
and the most senior person
told me that he still reviews
on the code line by line,
right, which is shocking to me
because it sounds so
painful nowadays.
I don't read code line
by line anymore, right.
This is too painful.
But he said, oh, he did it
because he wants to be able
to give feedback to
junior engineers
so that they can learn.
Okay. This is not
good or not bad.
And then it went to
junior engineers.
And, okay.
Do you read his reviews?
And they were like, no.
And the reason he's
told me, they told me
that because the feedback
is not actionable,
because the senior
engineer will say, "Okay,
do not write this if-else
function like this.
Write it like that."
But then those junior
engineers are not the people
who write the code, right?
It can tell AI, "Okay,
don't write this thing."
But it's not going to be
applicable for the future.
So, what the junior engineers
want feedback on is how
to write the instructions
for the code.
And that's something I feel like
GitHub is not quite designed
for right now, right, because I
think, with the new AI coding,
the artifact is no
longer the code.
Like GitHub was designed around
code as a main artifact, right?
You have the codebase.
People protect the codebase.
So, the code is the
main artifact.
But nowadays with AI coding,
the main artifact action is
the instructions.
How do you like the specs?
I think several coding
spec-driven development is
like how do you, if you have
a good spec, you can give it
to AI; it can generate
code, maybe even better
than what you currently have.
So, yeah. So, I think it's
a lot of work thinking
about designing, okay.
What would be the workflow
for us to work with AI
so that it can be more
meaningful, because a lot
of the workflows that we
have nowadays are legacy.
So, I guess it's like also part
of, like, human collaborations.
It's like, how do we get
different people to work
on a codebase effectively
with AI in the loop as well.
And another category of tools,
of problems I find
exciting, is the human-AI
environment interactions.
So, to make AI work better in
production, right, one way to go
is to make AI better and
do things better,
another way to
go is also to make
the world an easy environment
for AI to operate in.
So, one thing with AI coding is
that I have noticed
that AI works a lot better
with new codebases.
Right. Now, you have a new
codebase; AI can just do things.
It also works a lot better
with modular codebase.
Okay. It's like, okay.
Just build these new functions.
It's a lot easier than trying
to fix the old codebase.
So, there's a whole new category
of consulting firms that go
and retrofit the big
existing codebase
to make them more friendly to AI
coding, so make it more modular
with different separate
and massive monorepos
into smaller repos
and things like that.
And another example
is also API.
So, in the past, a
lot of the tools
and apps were built for humans.
And what humans want are
all the GUI, right,
like the graphic user
interface because,
humans, we are very visual.
We want to be able to,
if we go to Salesforce,
we want to open the
website; we go and see,
and here's a button
we want to click.
And we want the
color to look nice.
We want things to represent it.
But AI actually doesn't do
very well on the visual.
Right. Now, if you ask AI to
do Salesforce, you really want
to code a bunch of API
functions, so we see that a lot
of companies try to move
a lot more of their design
into API design, instead
of the GUI design.
And I think it's very clear to
see the usage of, first of all,
let's say you have a
tool like Salesforce.
You can see there's a
usage on the Salesforce,
how much of that
was used by human
and how much is used by AI.
You can see the distribution
changes a lot over time.
Another thing, more
physical world.
So, I work a lot with
robotics nowadays.
And a lot of the
arguments people have
against general purpose robots
is, like, why do we need a robot
that can do everything and
work everywhere instead
of just change my house or
change the road to be better,
easier for robots, right?
So, one example is a
food delivery robot.
Do you know these little food
delivery robots
that move around?
I think in the South
you see them a lot.
They're very cute.
They're very tiny.
They show up like this, so that
you can put the food inside,
and it takes it to
your home, and you open it.
And it's adorable.
So, I was talking to the team.
I was asking, so what is
a weird challenge you had
with this robot?
And they were like, oh.
The biggest challenge was the
robot couldn't cross the street.
So, when the robot
would go in the
street and the
light turned green,
and a lot of streetlights
need you to press a button
so that the light
can turn green.
But the robots do not have arms.
It's very tiny, so it
cannot press a button
to cross the street.
So, somebody has an
interesting innovation of,
if the robots can go
up to a pedestrian
and ask the person, "Hey.
Can you press
the button for me?"
There was some video online
and the pedestrian was like,
"What is happening, is
this robot asking me
to do manual labor for it?
I should be asking
you to do things,
not the other way around."
But, yeah.
So, he told me it's like
actually some cities,
they have this kind of thing.
It's like they call it
a streetlight API,
so that all this robotics
company can actually access the
city streetlight,
and they can tell it
when the light's
going to turn green.
And, instead of pressing
the button for the light
to turn green, you can
actually call the API
to turn the light green.
So, that's one example
of getting the world
to be more AI-
friendly long-term.
I think this is the
whole feel of it.
I think that we are
still very early,
because we still don't quite
know what use cases are going
to be possible and how we can
make the world better for it.
Another thing is, it's
pretty important for the robot
to operate in the real world.
It's kind of like
a revisability.
So, recently Claude Code
actually deleted my database.
So, I asked it to do an app, and
I want you deploy on a port.
It's like a Docker
Postgres port.
And I have another app
already using that port.
So, Claude was like, I saw
that the port is taken.
Let me clear it so that
we could deploy this app;
and then it completely deleted
the other Postgres database.
Wow. Smart.
So, I was mighty amused.
But was not frustrated because
I have a backup, right?
But it could happen, right?
So, for a lot of things that
happens in on your computer,
there's a way for you
to revert what happens.
Git is great for it;
if you submit a PR
or, like, make a commit
you don't like,
or it reverses the old commit.
But, for a lot of use cases,
you don't have that luxury.
So, let's say you ask an AI
agent to submit a form, right.
After you submit the form, maybe
the form, the data now lives
in somebody else's server.
You cannot undo it unless
you ask the server,
the form owner, to
delete it for you.
So, you don't have that luxury.
You cannot just transfer
money to another bank account
and then ask a bank account
to transfer it back.
They might.
But, if they are like the
scammers, if we want, right?
So, there are a lot of things
that, as we give AI more power,
more tools, it's just
the risk is just higher.
So, we need to design the
whole system around how
to make it very, very hard
for AI not to make mistakes
because mistakes can be very
costly and not reversible
for many, many use cases.
And especially working robotics,
it's important, more important
than ever because, if a
robot step on a child,
I don't think we can
just revert that, right.
The child's really hurt.
So, actually one of the
robotic companies I work
with, because they
want to use cases,
we say that they get asked for
a lot is elderly care, right?
I'm not sure any one of you
have to deal with elderly care.
It's extremely expensive.
Some people pay $20,000 a month
to take care of an
elderly parent.
So, the need
for it is very high.
But elderly care has a thing.
It's scary, right,
because a robot is heavy.
And robots has very
low battery life.
So, for example, have you
seen the Unitree G1 robot?
It's like yay high, right?
So, it's like 80 pounds.
So, it's metal, right.
Imagine that falling on you.
That does not feel good.
And you can do a lot of
things to help with it,
but one failure
is quite dumb.
This battery just dies.
So, let's imagine that the robot
is doing some walking, right,
and that the battery just dies.
So, the robot, mid-action,
can just like flop over.
So, it's quite challenging.
So, we're doing things.
Oh. Do you know about
the one-wheel accident?
Do you know the one wheel?
The one just has one wheel, and
they can go and ride around.
It looks very dangerous
but very cool.
So, they have one failure mode,
just like the Gotham suit a lot.
It's just like, if you're on
the wheel and the battery died,
you would just fly over there,
because the wheel
is stuck there.
So, that could
happen with robots.
Let's say it's like
the robots do a lot
of actions, and
the battery dies.
It would just have no
control over itself.
So, there are a lot of toolings,
work to make it safer.
Maybe detect, once a
battery is maybe low,
then you don't attempt
any complicated actions.
Or self-charging is a
very important feature
so that we develop, so that
even though it's robotic, okay.
If we're going to run out of
battery, let's move
back to the base.
And also, there are the rules
that we can do around safety.
How much time do we have left?
Yeah. Yeah.
So, I think there's
a lot of problems
that we can build
for AI, with AI.
I'm actually pretty excited
because one thing I realized is,
with AI, I get to build more
things, because
now I do not have
to do a lot of boring stuff.
I can just focus on
thinking about, okay.
What kind of new things, new
problems I want to solve.
And a lot of this boring stuff,
to be fair, I actually do not
like manually writing
code because, in college,
one thing I really hated
was vectorizations, right?
I had to do something,
it's, okay.
You have to make it super fast,
or writing if-else functions.
I never found that
very, very exciting.
But now, with AI,
upload a play code.
Now, with AI, you can
do that a lot faster.
So, we talk about software
defensibility for the product,
but another question that I
also think a lot about is,
how to make myself more
defensible in terms of AI,
right, because how do I make
sure that I can learn the skills
that AI won't automate.
So, in the early
days of ChatGPT,
one thing that I did spend time
on -- and I would love to learn
more from people how they do it,
what I call like a career audit.
So, for the whole week, I
actually went through and wrote
down everything that I did.
And I tried to think of, okay.
Can this thing be
automated by AI, right?
If it can, is there
someone already doing it?
Or, if cannot be AI, or
if it does not exist yet,
then maybe I can build it.
So, they give me a lot
of ideas and so give me
like a better understanding
of so, build code is a
term of AI exposure.
What percentage of your
job is exposed to AI?
And, the higher the
percentage, the higher chance
of the job being automated.
So, yeah. I'm going
to be curious
to see how people approach that.
So I think, just to bring it
home, I think about any software
that exists can be replicated.
And so, I spent the
last two years
in my last company to
think about, okay.
If that's the case, maybe
should I go beyond software?
So, I think of AI
agents as, an AI agent is
about performing actions, right?
In the earliest, in the
simplest form of action,
it's just like token, like
generates the next token,
which is the early days
of ChatGPT, LM, right?
It's just keep on generating one
token after another.
Should I turn to an essay, an
email, question answering.
And then the next category,
next level of actions are
digital actions, right.
Now, the agent can do fancy
things or can read files.
It can write into files, which
is important for coding.
It can code different APIs.
From GitHub API, it can call,
it can call image
generation API.
It can call whatever,
the banking
or internal API, external API.
It can do search.
Search is a very important
digital action.
I think this is the next tier.
I believe it's
physical actions.
So, for example,
now, instead of --
imagine, right, imagine that you
have an agent that's running
some code, maybe
they open Claude
or something on the terminal.
And then suddenly it says, okay.
For this to do complete
this task, maybe I need
to build small things.
It can run out and buy it.
Or it can do, okay.
I want to do this task,
like hosting an event.
Maybe you can think, okay.
For hosting event, I can
create a guest list.
I can invite a guest.
But I also need to go
out and buy some plates.
If you can send, get some robot
to do these physical actions,
that could be super cool.
So, I do think there's a next
another layer of action
in the real world, like
you do physical actions.
And I do think of just
like, physical AI
agents actually
do not look that different
from the AI agent
that we know today,
because an agent is
anything that can interact
with the environment,
right, take feedback
from the environment and
perform actions on it.
So, a coding agent, the
environment here is
like the computer, right.
And the action you can do
is like refi, wifi, edit.
So, it can perform actions.
It can receive.
It can perform actions
in the environment
by making changes to the file.
It can get feedback from
the environment first,
where it can try to run the
file, try to see the compile
to see if it passes a test.
So, that's how anization work;
and it's the same thing
with a physical
agent, but now the
environment is physical, instead
of just purely, purely digital.
And the action here is more
physical motions, like walk,
pick up things, placing
things, pushing, pulling.
And AI, we have seen that
it has worked quite well
with reasonings, right.
With AI, the initial AI agent,
we can see, being given a task,
it can reason through
step-by-step how
to accomplish the task, right?
Okay. If you want to do a
business app first,
I need to create a database.
I need to build as well.
I need to write a script,
and things like that.
And I have seen it; AI can
do the same thing for a lot
of the tasks in the real world.
Let's say if you ask
it, oh, do laundry,
you can first think, okay.
First, I need to collect
all the clothes.
Second, I need to take them
to the washing machines.
I can do a lot of random things.
So, I think its reasoning
part is pretty good.
I do think I have pretty
strong convictions
that AI is pretty
good at reasoning.
AI needs to give it a physical
understanding because I need to,
for digital AI, a
lot of the product,
a lot of environments
are very well-described
with documentations.
Not everything has
good documentations,
but ideally, a lot of APIs.
You know what endpoints
you can call, right.
It knows what parameters.
It expects, it knows, okay.
Here's the error code.
You know what that means.
But, for a physical wall,
we don't quite have
that nice description
of the wall.
There's no documentation about
how to handle an egg, right?
There's no one to say, Okay.
If you put this much force
into the egg, it will break.
Or like, if you put the leg
this way, you're going to fall.
So, that's not good description
of the physical environment.
So, that's the part that we
need to teach AI.
We humans, we learn how to
operate in the real world
to retry an error, right?
For a try, it takes like a long
time, maybe a year or so just
to learn just to
walk, like learning
to control the
muscles, the joints.
We don't have that
information encoded.
And that's why there's
a lot of effort going
to what is called
a world modeling,
like trying to model the world,
so that we can teach AI how
to understand and operate in it.
But, yeah.
So, I'm very excited about it.
So, actually, one of the
companies that I work
with have a demo
tomorrow for the robots.
They have this dog robot.
Unfortunately, they kind
of spare a humanoid.
Humanoids are really
cool to watch.
But, yeah.
Unfortunately. I think the
dogs are also very cute.
Yeah. If you want to
come, come for it.
And, if you want to talk
about robots, get in touch.
I'm trying to write more about
software defensibility and AI
for robotics in general.
Yeah. Thank you so
much, everyone.
[ Applause ]